let's get this show on the road
man 2079
we're playing in
2021
okay let's do a
let's do a nimzo slash queens indian
that's not something that we have played
often but it is my second opening after
the king's indian okay bishop d2 so
bishop d2 okay bishop d2 is a move it's
not considered theoretically topical
it's quite passive but it's been gaining
some popularity actually recently so
the nimso indian is a very easy opening
to pick up you basically just develop
your pieces
and then there are a couple of specific
setups that you should know okay so a3
we take on c3 that's kind of the point
of the nimzo indian it we're making it
harder for white to occupy the center
with e2e4
by weakening white's control over the e4
square and we do that by taking out the
knight on c3 off the board so one of the
the most typical nimzo indian setups
involves positioning your pieces as
follows you play b6 bishop b7
and then d6 knight bd7 so you create
these little holes for your pieces
and that is considered one of the most
solid setups
available in the nimzo indian so the
move d5 here
would be fine but not very not really in
the spirit of the nimzo indian so we are
going to play this in the spirit in the
names of indian we're going to play d6
and knight pd7 and this is
a very very common and very solid setup
because there are no weaknesses you know
now we have to continue improving our
position we positioned our pieces on the
squares we were supposed to position
them and now there are a couple of
subsequent
follow-up plans
so one of them is to play something like
queen to e7
and then push e6 e5
but a more aggressive idea that i really
like involves playing the move knight to
e4 which is a pretty natural move
and then following up with f5 i mean
this is an idea that you should be very
familiar with if you're you know over
1500 for example 94 and f5
this is a ubiquitous idea across many
different openings rook 8 d1
now of course we have the option of
eliminating
of subtracting white's bishop from the
board one week we one way we could play
this is to take the bishop and then
actually get the other knight around to
e4 another pretty classic
classic concept
i don't feel strongly about that one way
or the other the bishop on c3 does have
a pretty bright future especially if
white pushes d5 at some point so it it
might be worth taking that bishop off
the board even though our knight on e4
is a strong piece but we're just gonna
get the other knight to the same square
so it's not like we're really giving
away the knight
we're just replacing one knight with the
other unless he plays knight d2 which
would be a pretty passive move but it
would take the sting out of 94. okay
queen c2 i don't see a reason for us to
refrain
from shoving the other knight into the
outpost
knight d2 okay that was his idea
now we need to use some tactics
in order to preserve this knight on e4
does anybody see a way that we could
create a situation in which white cannot
take on e4 yeah so we play queen g5 this
is a a classic move and this this is a
couple of ideas we're threatening
obviously we're threatening okay and
white immediately blunders yeah white
white makes it unfun
ooh
but there is one thing after king h1
i think i see a much sexier move than
knight f2 check so we're hoping
he resigned
yeah i was hoping he wouldn't resign
let's see let's start with that actually
does anybody see
does anybody see the most efficient way
to check mate after king h1
so queen takes e2 wins obviously knight
f2 check wins
but nike three check i think is the
fastest mate
h takes g3 and rook f6 with rook h6 to
follow there is no smothered mate
because white can give up an exchange on
f2
but this is a pretty situation where
despite it being white to move there's
just nothing that he can do
just remember this this is a classic
mechanism like
white can put a rook on f2 we'll just
take it
yeah so this is mate
pretty underwhelming game we didn't
really get a chance to do anything
yeah so
the nimzo indian is one of those
openings that kind of flies under the
radar
like i don't think there's a chessable
course for the nimzo indian even though
it's it's definitely top three in terms
of like objectively best openings
especially when it's paired with
something good against knight f3 so
against knight f3 you can play a bunch
of different things you can play bogo
indian you can still give this check
the queen's indian is b6 and then you
can play
d5
and after knight c3 bishop before is the
rogozin which has been extremely popular
in in the last few years
and of course white can also play the
catalan which is a big reason that a lot
of people don't play the nimzo indian
they don't like facing the catalan but
honestly the catalan at like a level
below 2500 is not that scary
like all you really need to do if you
are black against the catalan is choose
a setup and learn it there's like five
or six different variations that all
lead to
uh very very decent positions for black
and the simplest is probably to play the
main line to play bishop e7
castles and then d take c4 and if you
want to play like the pros
uh recently does anybody know
uh let's see who has who is in tune with
top level chess what move
in this position
is extremely popular nowadays whereas it
was
never even a move before does anybody
know
yeah b5
and the reason that this has never been
a move is because of a4
and this was always considered
very bad because it was considered
forced that black had to play b4 you
cannot afford your entire pawn structure
to be destroyed like this and you cannot
play a6 because there were kings and yet
these people did play bishop or a6 or
bishop b7 and this line has become
ridiculously popular recently and it
turns out that if white just grabs the
pawns first of all white cannot take
here because if a takes b5 the rook is
exposed
and if white takes ba6 knight a6 queen
c4 and after bishop d5 black gets a
pretty big initiative in return for the
pawn and this line basically equalizes
so
this is worth exploring if you need a
line with black against the catalan
there's a lot more to this obviously
like white can avoid this by playing
queen a4
but this allows black to
enter the favorable main line a6
queen takes c4 and b5 the reason people
started playing queen c2 is that after
a6 a4 became extremely popular
like this move became the way to fight
for an advantage whereas earlier
people had been taking automatically on
c4 and getting into this variation
uh which is now considered completely
fine for black but there's still a lot
to
a lot to learn here
um so definitely you should learn the
catalan if you're a nimzo player
and then you should learn the nimzo
proper because it's it's pretty vast
brandon played e3 against me in the
tournament which is the rubenstein
variation probably the most reputable
line
queen c2 is the kind of more ambitious
variation
and
you know there's a bunch of other moves
bishop d2 and our opponent played bishop
g5 is the leningrad variation g3 here is
possible of course white can play knight
f3 and then
black has the option of transposing into
the ragosan with d5
uh and there's the move f3 which i've
played with white there's the move a3
which is quite similar to f3
yeah i mean there's there's a ton to
learn if you're an mso player but the
good thing about playing the nimso is
that most of the time you can kind of
improvise and if you know the main
setups
if you like understand where the pieces
and where the pieces usually go
then you can generally get a decent
position against most lines
and one of those very typical setups is
indeed
to take the knight
and the idea of bishop d2 of course is
to take back with the bishop to keep the
integrity of the queenside pawn
structure and then we play b6
and black is slightly worse in this
setup like i don't dispute that the
engine usually gives like 0.4.5
in these types of positions but it's
really really solid like black has no
weaknesses every piece is doing
something and it's very easy to play
but generally the reason that white is
considered to be better
in these structures has to do
with the move d5
so i actually think queen c2 queen c2 is
fine
but if i were white i would actually
keep the bishop with bishop e1
i would keep the bishop pair
and the reason i think a lot of people
would hesitate to play a move like
bishop one is that you'd think well the
bishop is terrible anyone but
again when you're discussing and you're
thinking about peace placement peace
placement is often temporary
whereas a bishop air is a more
long-lasting advantage you're eventually
going to improve the bishop
and on the next move you can potentially
push the d-pawn up to d5
so for example f5 white can already play
d5
forcing black to play e5 and now white
has a clamp on some of these squares
i would keep the bishop here queen c2 is
fine f5 rookie d1
so we take the bishop we get the other
knight around to e4
notice that
d5 here
sometimes this is a pawn sacrifice
that is used in order to open up the
position and
kind of introduce weaknesses into
black's position but specifically here
it might not work so edcd
now which way should black take who can
tell me bishop or knight takes what is
better
well knight attacks the queen and is
tempting for that reason but again do
not be lulled into a move just because
it creates a threat
and if you think tactically you will
realize that 95 succumbs to bishop c4
very very nasty move
it does not win the night because you
have c6 but just look at this freaking
position i mean just look at this
if if dictionary had like a definition
for good night against bad bishop this
would probably be the position
so for that reason you should take with
a bishop
and you might say ah but white can take
and sack the exchange and do that again
but
it's the same position except why to
sacrifice an exchange that's a little
bit
of a of a steep price to pay also you've
gotten rid of the bishop
and if queen c4
then you still play c6
classic concept you basically give away
the pawn but at least the knight is
unpinned and you're still up in exchange
um
anyway so d5
was interesting but i don't think
it was all that effective
queen c2 is i mean our opponent played
totally fine up until the very end of
the game
maybe knight d2 is inaccurate on account
of queen g5
and as you can tell when you put a
significant amount of pressure on even
players in like the 2000 range they tend
to collapse pretty quickly
so what should white have done instead
that's actually a good question
first of all knight takes c4 loses the
game bishop takes c4 this is a classic
fork
attacking the queen attacking checkmate
now bishop f3 is very tempting putting
the bishop
directly opposite our bishop
so how does this line go let's calculate
so we play knight takes d2
right if white takes back on d2 then we
take the bishop and we win
so bishop takes bishop
now we take the rook
the classic uh line where i'm saying
classic a lot but
basically both sides are taking each
other's pieces and in such scenarios you
have to look for desperados right you
have to say all right well i'm probably
going to lose the knight anyway so i
might as well give it up for as much as
i can take and we have the incredibly
strong move knight takes e3
and if f takes c3 we don't rush to take
the bishop we actually can take on e3
again
check
and then we take the bishop on the next
move we're up two pawns
we're up two pawns
by the way if you're playing white
interesting little side note if you're
playing white here and you're trying to
salvage as much material as possible
what should you do in this position
like if you're white you shouldn't
automatically take the knight
yeah queen d2 or queen c1
queen detour queen c1 is actually the
best move because the knight is pinned
so at this point we have nothing better
to do than to take the bishop and white
limits his material losses to one pawn
still obviously very bad for white not
what you would want
and that doesn't leave white with too
many options i mean there is the move g3
but that's very very weakening and we
can already start thinking about lifting
the rook up to h6 you actually have a
good amount of nimzo indian winds
that happen
precisely with this kind of attack
like exactly this kind of arrangement of
pieces where you play queen g5
white falls asleep on the king side and
before you know there's a rook on h6
you know there's sacrifices on
h2
and you can actually win a pretty
brilliant
you know pretty brilliant attacking
games
with this configuration of pieces let me
see what i can find
here there's a cool game actually
blackbeard gm
and you'll get to see that i'm not
making making stuff up about
you know about the setup that i just
showed you that it's actually a thing
that very strong players do
so farinetos was a grandmaster schneider
i guess is an im yeah i am he's still
alive
so nimzo indian queen c2 variation
but you can see a3 bishop c3 b6 so
here's that setup e3 d6 before an ipd7
so you can see that even strong players
are fans of the setup
okay so here you can see that farindos
has managed to keep his bishop pair
and the bishop is on b2 rather than d2
and here black plays another very
typical move for these types of
positions which is c5 and you you
control part of the center
you create a good amount of central
tension
dc and now you you take with the
opposite pawn
classic motif bc you have dc
if dc you play bc this is also a thing
in the sicilian by the way when you play
f5
if white takes the e pawn you take with
the g pawn you i think there's even a
name for this where you take with the
other pawn anyways
b5 f5
castles black plays e5
so this creates a backward pawn but at
least it shuts the bishop out
and after 91 there is that queen g5 move
again
and white just kind of starts shuffling
his pieces aimlessly and boom rook f6
and white thinks oh i got you f3
trapping the knight
trapping the knight
does anybody can anybody spot and this
is not an extraordinary move but it's a
it's a strong attacking move what do you
do how do you save the knight
do you sacrifice it if so how
yeah you play rook g6 simply simple move
fv you have bishop takes c4 attacking
the queen and creating bishop takes g2
which is a massive threat so rook g6
rook d1
i like how black just chills on e4 no
problem
but here white plays queen b3
understandable move
and that's actually why white played
rook d1 because now the knight can
escape back to f6 but you're going to
lose the d6 pawn
you're going to lose the backward pawn
but all of a sudden notice how white's
pieces have just sort of departed away
from the king side
bang knight g3
hg queen takes g3
and it doesn't seem like black has any
threats but the problem is just that
white cannot get black's pieces out of
you can't smoke the queen out of g3
easily so black is not in much of a
hurry and black just because rook h6
rook h2
and then e4 striking at the center
and in just overwhelming attack queen h4
threatening checkmate on h1
check check
take on e1 oh beautiful move sacking the
queen
oh man bishop takes c4 wow and rook
takes e3 with a mating attack
that's that's actually pretty lovely
white has to go here and then you
basically just take everything and at
the end of the day you're gonna be up a
piece
great attack i didn't even notice the
black at sac to queen at the end of this
rook takes e1
simple but very very pretty um
yeah like four pawns
but anyways you you get the point the
nimzo is not just
a a lame positional opening it's
you know it is a gateway to some pretty
cool attacks
especially in this
particular kind of structure thank you
for the tier one
yeah anyways um f3
was just a terrible blunder
and after queen takes e3 check
oh it had a very cool attack had a
failed attack by the player playing
white
why take with the other pawn
oh
yeah to create an imbalance in the
center and also to keep the d file
closed because white has easier access
to the d file than black does
anyways all right guys i'm going to call
it it's it's past four so
thank you everybody for the support
pretty good blitz today
definitely will stream tomorrow and uh
i'll see y'all later
you